you don't say squeeze olodio se
retrouvent pour une vidéo un peu
spéciale je déteste les gens qui disent
ça donc je me déteste plus tard je vous
ai demandé de m'envoyer des photos de
vous avec une tête bizarre beau gosse
what the fuck est en fête avec ces
photos là on va faire des mels et on va
aussi probablement rire un ce serait
bien je vois déjà m'avoir donné plein
plein plein de photos et we go alors ça
mon gars c'est parti je suis grunge
génère con pour ceux qui connaissent pas
ce gros chien film d'horreur alors le
perso principal n'est pas cette femme
qui fait peut-être soudain vous choquer
mais ces attentions
voilà celle là vous avez peur bonne nuit
non mais oh oui oh oui je laime basij te
baise cheveux du krav maga crédible
non mais c'est déjà même ça j'espère que
tu es content d'être en phase avec ça tu
as pris quelqu'un au pif dans le vague
d'eau en photo c'est horrible fait mon
frère non pas de ça on est d'accord ou
pas c'est un peu ça dans un an j'aurais
déjà pécho aussi dont un an j'aurais
pécho d'abord à eux je suis pas pu se un
os os
tu es ma chère jeu postionner c'est la
meilleure des envie de faire autre chose
quand même j'ai pas de l'inspiration me
vient d'un coup de menton est plutôt
gros effectivement de quoi faire tomber
on va voir ça peut devenir un pokémon
sags extraordinaire regardez n'y a pas
un début de pokémon c'est pas mal
en mai ces quads et le visage de la
tristesse mais faut pas être triste
comme ça dit non
what je comprends pas j'espère que tu
vas mieux je vous souhaite plein de
bonheur ou la vidéo qui part en bas d'un
coupé à tous mais trop tôt mais tu te
trompe complètement de la tristesse quoi
au home est celle ci est la meilleure
idée du jour [ __ ] vous le sentez je
sais que vous le sentez arrive et ana
c'est génial on dirait pas que ça sort
[ __ ] fantastique je n'ajoute dans le
dossier chose étrange que j'aime
beaucoup et qui font peur maintenant à
les suivants en fait on va faire ça on
va pas faire des mecs qu'on va s'amuser
que vous photo quoi mon plus beau
sourire alors c'est comment trouver
cette photo tu tapes en manche sur
google et attention aux plats les la
direccte reste un tuto de merde comment
être un enfant vous le sentez arrivé
voilà le dommage le sang est lui aussi
le sens aux énoncés non halal mais les
doigts dans le nez d'un dans le nez dans
un an on a créé un truc genre né ception
n'est celle shon voilà bah moi ça me
faisait rire aussi pris à ma
participation au jeu voie opaque ou avec
mes capacités en photoshop âge va
d'ailleurs je fais ça sur un logiciel de
montage vidéo vous dire à quel point je
suis une merde on peut faire deux choses
soit partir sur un délire de bananes
voilà qui repasse les rides soit pas à
me faire le banat devoir s'en fout de
nos possibilités
cyprien avec une ride normal cyprien
avec une ride banane là on y vient
bordel regardez où ça vient
ob oui non là je suis parti en couille
j'ai un truc avec l'aîné je vois c'est
cyprien et voici maintenant s'ils
prennent halles ou banane aprilia
l'homme qui a adoré la banane au point
d'avoir des lunettes banane mais sont
aussi disponibles en édition pastèque
voilà c'est une création de ma part qui
va sûrement pas du tout de vendre ses
six mois seront offerts à la sûreté des
taux à mon dieu ils nous attaquent
bordel on l'appelle tétons man j'ai
volonté tout juste de voir ça riera
presse que tu vas devenir affreuse
créatures il vous a racheté tour et vous
les montre il s'en est même fait d'une
[ __ ] de dieu pour mieux voir voté
tourne à céder loglo bon gars comme
image avant après méfiez-vous [ __ ] on
va bien vous en faites pas vous m
on tape la pose pour toi avec ma clique
des javas zoom et ensuite tu as djendjen
mais coderre rêve de les faire score
exceptionnel on va des tours et le
museau de ce terrible animal à la
douanière a bien pouvoir le exactement
comme ça voilà on voit qui a été de la
photo n'est pas ouf mais bon ça fait des
dégâts mais en petit regarder on
pourrait en petit ça le fait grave au
petit c'est génial
c'est tout pourri mais richesse borloo
ait cet oeil là pas la place pour mettre
là où assis comme ça à regarder
oh oui c'est beau ça le fait un peu
quand même je trouve si on appuie si on
a bu de l'alcool ça le fait non ça va
elle théophile il chute à daha wassa le
fait pour elle mais alors pour lui
c'était trop mais pour elle c'est
l'excellent hockey ans ferme ta bouche à
oreille krav maga la tête étant gamin tu
avais un sacré grand fond d'idées si
vous avez caché sera regarde on peut
presque met deux visages sur ton visage
sa rentrée à la place pizza c'est
exceptionnel ça c'est un don un don non
à l'envers c'est pas non c'est pas fou
hein c'était quand même mieux à
l'endroit est ce que quelqu'un est
étonné tête haute et au thé tonné non
ton sosie me merci c'est par oui ce qui
là encore de là je vais forcément ces
cadeaux liliane tiens toi aussi tu as la
petite barbe d'adolescents un peu nul
quoi c'est comme moi c'est gentil
concrètement c'est ça qu'on a sur le
visage en fait alors allez y a moyen de
faire un truc aussi un alors le seul ou
comment faire assez le fit plus
originales et attendait alors là la
blague ultime après tant d'années
passées à être coupés manger et humilié
devant ses collègues du frigo le
saucisson rouge a décidé de prendre sa
revanche
mais la bouffe et péta et majencia pas
de cette vidéo c'est quand même pas
partie en steaks ou devait faire les
mêmes pura fé démontage bon voilà en
tout cas n'hésitez pas mais l'ado ça
vous a plu mrc avoir regardé je suis
désolé si c'est assez court mais c'est
que les montages près d'une plombs parce
que je suis nul en montage photo je suis
baird voilà merci d'avoir regardé on se
construit bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo car tout le monde piste
elle appelle l'application je lui dis
j'en ai mal employé
[Musique]